I grew up in Sacramento California and
my mom was a costume designer my dad was
a director playwright and my parents
always joked around that I was born in a
trunk because I truly just eat slept and
and would Breathe theater I'm Chloe
Condon and this is my journey to
becoming a Google developer advocate
[Music]
I attended college at San Francisco
State University where I majored in
theater performance and yeah I learned a
lot about just how to communicate
different ideas be it musically or
dramatically after I graduated I think
my hope with my degree was to be a
full-time actress I booked my very first
musical Xanadu where I was on roller
skates the whole show and you know my
picture was on billboards and in the
newspaper there was a big cardboard
cutout of me in the lobby but I was only
getting paid a couple hundred dollars
and I realized okay this is not a
sustainable way to live in the Bay area
so I put a big focus on trying to find a
steady nine to five Monday through
Friday job I was a children's birthday
party Entertainer I was a summer camp
counselor I worked for a little bit as a
virtual personal assistant I was a
account executive working in sales for a
little bit and then I got into office
management and executive assistant work
I had this kind of weird Cinderella
complex where I was by day sweeping the
floors cleaning things up and then at
night literally getting standing
ovations and thunder supplies I did so
many musicals over over my time after
college I did Shrek the Musical 25th
Annual Putnam County Spelling Bee Carrie
the musical Pirates of Penzance multiple
hairsprays Singing in the Rain Jerry
Springer the Opera my final show that I
did ironically enough before I made the
transition into engineering was How to
Succeed In Business Without Really
Trying which is very much a theme I feel
like in my Tech Career I actually
decided to make the transition into Tech
because of the talk that I heard at
Google and I happened to see a talk
about getting young women specifically
Elementary School Middle School age
interested in computer science and it
really got me thinking as I'm sitting
there watching this talk I never had
anyone in my life that I could look to
who looked like me acted like me sounded
like me who worked as an engineer or
worked in this space so after I saw that
talk at Google I started looking up all
these things like girls who code and all
these different programs that were for
much younger girls so I lamented to my
boyfriend you know my ship is sailed I
wish that this this stuff was around
when I was younger and he said you can
still learn like there are resources
online and and it literally took someone
saying to me this is still a possibility
and something that you can do that um
just ignited my interest and I ended up
going the boot camp route and attended
hackbright Academy which is an all
women's software engineering boot camp
in San Francisco it was one of the
hardest things I've done in my life but
I'm so glad that I did it I had a very
big Epiphany when I was in my boot camp
where we were all presenting our final
projects that we had to create for the
boot camp and all the women in my boot
camp seemed very nervous to be
presenting their topics and they're
looking at me like I'm crazy going like
why are you smiling and I said this is
the best easiest part all you have to do
is go in front of a bunch of people and
talk about our project and something
clicked for me there which is that a lot
of Engineers don't like public speaking
or being on camera or being able to
explain Concepts to people so that
really ignited my passion for the
developer relations space and developer
advocacy and developer evangelism I use
my background as an actress every single
day in my job as a developer Advocate a
lot of the scripting that I do you
really are telling a story no matter
what it is that you're writing or trying
to explain also just general theater
etiquette I think is also a huge part of
being able to like create good and
interesting content people learn better
when they're engaged in having fun so I
think a lot about my time as a
children's theater performer where I was
playing a crayon on stage where you know
it it takes a lot to get the attention
of a four or five-year-old I'm willing
to bet that it's even more difficult to
get the attention of a engineer I think
it's so important that we have people
that represent all walks of life be it
musical theater people or wrestlers or
whatever your background may be there
truly is so much creativity to be had in
this space so if you think that your job
is just going to be sitting behind a
computer you know crunching numbers
there's so much more in this industry
that you can do and that can help
fulfill you know what it is you want to
be able to contribute to to technology
[Music]